mn où l'on reparle de l'aéroport de
notre dame des landes près de nantes les
opposants redoutent dans les prochaines
heures une nouvelle intervention des
forces de l'ordre pour les expulser
d'une ferme promise à la destruction
malongo ils se sont donnés rendez vous
tôt ce matin des militants déterminés à
empêcher la destruction de cette maison
située sur la zone d'aménagement du
projet d'aéroport pour rentrer dans ce
secteur il faut montrer patte blanche
les accès sont bloqués tous ici
redoutent une intervention des policiers
carrière le tribunal de nantes a ordonné
l'évacuation de cette maison pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de signes de
présence policière là dans les environs
mais à la fois ça veut dire que s'ils
viennent pas aujourd'hui à viendront un
autre jour donc c'est pas forcément
rassurant pour le moment l'ambiance est
donc bon enfant mais la vigilance reste
de mise
ces militants occupent cette maison de
cuisine semaine date du départ des
propriétaires légaux
cette ferme et un de leurs symboles pour
sa démolition signifierait le début des
travaux de l'aéroport est donc une
rupture de contrat moral avec le parti
socialiste
c'est à dire il n'y aura pas de travaux
pas de début de travaux avant
la fin des recours il ya plein de
recours encore il n'est pas question que
les travaux démarrent et jouer sur les
mots en disant que détruire une maison
ce n'est pas le début des travaux c'est
pour nous c'est insensé
de son côté la préfecture a assuré que
cette procédure d'expulsion n'avait
aucun rapport avec le début des travaux
ce projet d'aéroport prévu pour être
achevé en 2017 est au point mort depuis
un an les vacances de pâques matin